Hi. Greetings, everybody.
My name is Mike.
I'm going to present,
the business case for Semantic
Data Management.
This is a consolidation
of what
I've learned over
the past almost
four decades of being
the therapist,
scribe, and analyst
for the data
management industry.
Alright. So first,
let's start off
by understanding
that there is a prime goal,
what I call a prime directive
for data management,
and that is to ensure that all
the users have trust
and confidence
that the data that
they're using
for their applications,
is true to origin.
And they should do so,
without the need
for reconciliation
and without the need
for multiple
data transformations.
If you think about it,
and we put this in
context for you,
you have a right to,
want I'm gonna say a right to
expect the data that you're
using to be true to
original intent.
Right? Not transformed, not,
mismatched or incongruent,
because it represents
real things.
Right? So it should be defined
at the most granular atomic
level to actually be able to
capture the reality
of the things
that it's represented.
It should be available
when you need it,
when, when your,
analysts want it.
They should be
able to get it,
themselves as they think about
what they need.
So it's a key part
of your asset
inventory along with your
processes and
your technologies
and your requirements.
The format should support,
scenario based
analytics. Right?
You you don't want it to be
stuck in the rigid
technology that,
you have to then
kind of unravel
before you can use. Right?
So it should be flexible.
We need it to be traceable as
it flows across
our systems and
through our calculations and
into our aggregation
processes.
We'd like it to
be testable for
fit for purpose,
to make sure it matches all
the logic requirements for
processing as well
as the quality
requirements, and that should
be done automatically.
We'd like it to be
self describing
so that the meaning
of the data
is embedded in
the content itself
and reusable. Right?
There's building blocks for us
to put the data to work.
And I will tell you that this
is all completely achievable.
That's completely
achievable right now.
Without a huge investment
in technology,
but it does
require organizational
adjustment. And in
order to do that,
the, the stakeholders must
understand it. They must have
cognition about
the problem and the,
pathway to solutions.
And there must be
leadership because,
this is an act of change,
and we wanna make sure that we
can deal with
the organizational
challenges that exist.
And those are the primary
obstacles for implementing any
new paradigm change that this
represents. So
let's take a look
at the challenges. Right?
So first we should recognize
that there are,
an infrastructure based on
relational technologies,
that are well over
fifty years old.
It's a lifetime
in technology.
That technology
sometimes leads
to wrong outcomes
that seem like
they are appropriate,
but actually wind
up being false
narratives in
today's technology
environment. And
that's compounded
by cultural obstacles,
associated with
organizational change.
Alright. So let's take a look
at these things
at in in-depth.
Right? And the technology,
of course,
is the biggest part of it,
but we have
fragmentation of our
technology, and we
all know that.
Silos exist,
functional silos,
process silos,
business silos,
geographic silos.
And those silos are managed
independently.
And sometimes we
have technology
that is different
in each silo. That technology
is driven by proprietary
data models,
proprietary quality engines,
proprietary glossaries,
and they don't
match each other.
So we've done things
independently,
not reusable.
We're looking at
an environment
where we have a couple
pair. Right?
Location based processing,
where you have
a column and a row,
you know, expressed as a table
linked with joins
and keys where
relationships have
been constructed
explicitly, and
we've done stuff
to optimize because
we have lots
of data that we
have to manage.
We've been copying data and
moving into the silos and
torturing it to death and
transforming it
and renaming it
to make sure that it
fits the glossary
that drives the software that
propels the data model that
drives the application.
That has result in a brittle
infrastructure that
is inflexible,
and sometimes we are afraid to
change it, not
well documented,
and it drives critical
applications.
This is what we refer to as
technical debt,
plus we have hard time tracing
it as it flows
through our systems,
both technical lineage
and the business
provenance for
the calculations.
You combine that with concepts
that seem appropriate,
like the single
version of the truth,
which was appropriate when you
only had one
repository of data.
But now we
the reality is there
are many, and we're not gonna
be able to get our arms around
all of the repositories of all
of our functional applications
across the world.
So we just have
to kind of accept
that standard standardization
of meaning is,
a better strategy
than trying to force
fit everything
into a single model
or into a centralized
repository. And
that model itself,
right, we we we
understand the value
of a canonical model describes
relationships. Right?
That's important.
But having one model that
describes everything,
is just not practical.
It would be out of date before
it was finished,
and you would spend all your
time trying to catch up with
the pace of your activity,
and that is not what
we're trying to do.
These problems,
these technological
problems and
objective problems lead us to
the two big
challenges. Right?
We have, multiple
identifiers.
We have, codes all
over our systems.
We've changed and
modified those
for various contacts.
We're we're we're
having a difficult
time making sure that this is
the same as that,
which is compounded,
of course, because there's no
meaning that's
been locked down.
And and meaning
is is different
when you have, front office
transactions process
versus a back
office legal and,
a settlement process.
So identity and
meaning, have become,
incongruent. You
combine that with,
you know, it seems
logical. Right?
We try to create a a,
an application
for an important
customer, but we do that over
and over and over again,
making lots of
micro decisions,
becomes hardwired and
yet another silo.
Without business
rules that have
been documented,
they're not machine
executable,
and we're operating off of,
next quarter spreadsheet with
the pace of business,
trying to push things,
so we wind up doing mostly
tactical activities to get us
out of the fire rather than
looking at
the problem strategically
as one that you can fix.
And we have to
be careful about
this quest for
magic solutions.
Right? Everybody that sells
technology always
says, you know,
this is the one
solution you need.
It might even seem like I'm
gonna sell magic,
but this is really
just conceptual,
understanding of
how things work.
Right? So if you look at those
challenges, and now let's take
a look now at the implications
of those challenges.
And these are
actual quotes that
I've been collecting
over the years
from people who are
going through the,
kind of, the data journey.
First one is, we can't
find this stuff.
Right? We don't
have a connected
inventory of our assets.
We made lots of copies.
We, we've changed
those copies.
We don't have
a process to prevent
duplication, so we don't know
where to go to get the data.
So it's a big problem of even
what exists and where do I get
it multiplied by,
the fact that it
doesn't match.
Right? So we have a hard time
integrating it, linking it,
making sure that
this is the same
as that, and,
we miss new we
have this problem
of same word,
different meaning,
different words,
same meaning.
A nuance is not passed
across processes,
and it comes from
using nomenclature
as the key for its activity.
I love this quote
at the end, right,
where it says, my projects end
up as expensive death marches
of cleansing, reconciliation,
manipulation just to
make the software
work. And that
story gets repeated
over and over again.
Because we're doing
it, in our silos,
we, began a local IT group to
build it specifically for me.
So we're not
coordinating across
processes, and
there's conflicts
and priorities and
winds up, being,
a bunch of,
independently defined designed
activities that leads to,
a lack of confidence
in usually
in technology for
being able to
implement what we want.
And you pull it
all together and
what we have is the lack of
trust in the data.
It's not fit for purpose.
We spend seventy
percent of our
time doing data
janitorial work
just to make sure
that the data
is right for an application.
We do that over and
over and over again.
I call this the bad data tax.
And I've done I've
done the research.
Actually, I've done
the research twice,
once with IBM and another time
with PwC to,
validate that this is at least
thirty percent of
your operating
expense just wasted. Right?
And we've allowed data to lose
consistency and
precision of meaning.
We've got it stuck
in these rigid,
ancient technology,
environments so that we can't
do what we need to in terms of
automation and
straight through
processing. We're not getting
leverage off of our expensive
technology investments.
We have these
complex analytical
models that,
we're just spending all this
time trying to
make sure the data
works and the models
don't match,
and we're running around doing
fire drills and putting
out brush fires.
And mostly we're missing
opportunities for
upselling and
cross selling and innovation.
We can't understand
context for
legal or for finance
or for marketing.
And, of course,
I'm in the financial
industry.
The regulators
have a hard time
unraveling
the aggregates because
they're trying to
feed different
models looking
at systemic risk
types of, applications.
The truth is not
gonna fix this
by continuing to do the same
thing over and over
and over again.
You're not gonna fix this by
adopting more
proprietary schemas,
managing that rigid pipeline,
or trying to force
fit data into
legacy data models that were
created for specific
applications.
We have to look at this thing
differently, which
is why I focus on,
these two concepts. Right?
I'm not gonna shy
away from them.
One is semantic.
It just says meaning,
and the other one
is standards.
So these are wonderful ideas.
We should not worry
about the the,
the dreaded o word of ontology
is a fantastic Let me see if I
can demystify this for you.
Starts with, four concepts,
four standards
concepts of which
is a scaffolding for
everything else.
Right? And the first one,
the most important
one is the ability
to reconcile identity
against a single,
permanent, unique,
unchangeable identifier
in the cloud.
You know, it's a, you know,
individualized
resource identifier
or a resource locator.
Forget what it's called.
It is a ability
to have a single
precise granular
identifier for
everything to which
all of the other
systems get linked to. Right?
So you should think of this as
the Rosetta Stone capability
that allows you to not have to
move the data.
You just link it
up to its identity
in the cloud.
You combine that
with ontologies.
Right? So there there are two
sides of this coin.
First is, can we
model precision?
And and the answer
is yes. We can.
Right? We know how to capture
what subject matter
experts tell
us to in the way things work,
boxes and line diagrams.
But the magic here is that we
can express it
now in standards
using the triples,
the other word,
the gift of the Department
of Defense.
Understanding triples is
straightforward.
Just recognize
that couple pair,
current relational technology
is location based. Right?
It's a column row
with tables,
joins, keys, and explicitly
defined relationships.
A triple is a sentence
structure.
Two nouns, they
call them subject
and object, linked by a verb
called a predicate.
All of those things
are precisely
defined at their most
granular level.
So they become building blocks
that you can then reuse for
applications because
they capture
concepts. It's
not necessary to
be an expert at how to write,
SPARQL queries, but,
you should
understand the basic
philosophy behind
how it works.
And then, of course,
the final part is
business rules
that are also, machine
executable in,
a semantic language.
So rules and
identity and meaning
come together. You
should remember
the semantic trinity. Right?
Identify, describe,
and express.
That's the goal.
With those standards,
we get these fantastic
capabilities.
Right? So the first one is,
quality by math. Right?
It's they're all
axiomatic statements,
and and if it doesn't match
the structure of
the ontology,
then it doesn't get imported
into the system.
So bad data cannot
get into your
system in the first place.
You're not running
around trying
to find it and clean it.
It's done automatically.
These are concepts.
They're like tinker
toy building
blocks that you just kind of
create and put together,
and you get to reuse them
application by application.
So you take identity
and meaning,
and you add to that time,
and you can express
almost every
context with those
three things.
And source is
important because
you want to make
sure the quality
of the data is fit for
its intended use.
Right? So this is all mostly
about describing the data,
not about the values.
Sometimes it's
critical for you
to multisource or triangulate
to make sure that the value is
accurate as well.
With semantic standards,
we can and actually
because it's
linked to the identifier,
we can track it as it flows
across all of our systems,
goes through our
calculation engines.
We can, manage our,
privacy and our
security concerns.
We can prove to our,
auditors that we know,
how it flows and
we have a control
environment. Governance,
which is mostly about quality
and definition and
requirements capture,
is all done automatically.
So governance
becomes simplified
and valuable. Right?
It's not onerous governance.
It is what do you
need and let's
go focus on getting it and and
integrating it
into our semantic
environment. It's all
machine readable,
so humans can understand it as
well as machines,
and it's done on
a continuously
tested basis. So
there's no big
bang releases that you have to
worry about. You
can add modular
components, and they're always
continually tested of whether
it is logically valid or of
the right structure.
So with those capabilities,
there are kinda
two things that
I look at.
One is why we do it,
and the other one
is what we do.
And these kinda cross
over each other.
Right? And we do this for
straightforward
reasons. Right?
We wanna operate efficiently.
We wanna automate
our processes.
We wanna make
sure that we have
control over
the data for privacy
and for, regulatory
compliance.
We wanna give our
data scientists
flexibility to follow
their intuition.
We wanna be able to
link up products,
transactions, and customers so
we can upsell and
cross sell our
activities. We we do that by
building connected
inventories,
by facilitating
the integration
of data across our
organization,
and by managing the access to
the data at a data
point level,
not a system level,
a data level,
so that we are
ensured of privacy,
management constraints.
Let me drill down to this just
a little bit deeper.
So I think this is
really the essence
of the business value side of
the business. Right?
And we'll do this
in the standard
three c's of cost,
capability,
and control. So as
I said before,
this is about thirty percent
savings minimum,
because we've
standardized meaning
and standard identity and we
have the entitlement control,
Integration becomes
simplified.
We can, get rid of redundant
systems and consolidate
activities,
and we can achieve
automation.
So the cost savings alone are
overwhelming. But, really,
we're doing this
to facilitate,
innovation. Right?
We wanna make sure that our
analysts can
follow the what if
scenarios that are required so
we can test out ideas.
We wanna be able to look at
things from different
perspectives,
and we don't wanna be,
forced to have to restructure
data just to look at
it from a different
view, like a risk risk view,
not the same thing
as a legal view,
not the same thing as
a financial view,
a marketing view,
not the same thing as
a regulatory view.
We should be able
to look at all
of that,
by asking questions
of the data
rather than
restructuring its,
its format.
And then the goal
is to establish
what the regulators in our
industry called,
a control environment,
which is defined, attract,
with systems of
record so we can
comply with our obligations,
so we can aggregate things on
a consistent basis across our
organization. So when
you look at that,
it's kind of an overwhelming
value side.
But there's a cost
associated.
There are challenges,
and and we have to be honest
about the challenges
as well. Right?
So let's take a look at this
idea of data centric,
and and I think
a lot about this.
I'm, like, wondering,
you know,
what exactly does it mean?
So I stole this quote.
I think sums it up
properly. Right?
It's not about
the technology.
This technology works
as advertised.
This is about cognition and
understanding and making sure
that people get the joke and
believe in the possibility.
Because once you do that,
it becomes obvious
that this is
the way we should be operating
our organization.
In order to do that,
we have to manage
two critical,
inhibitors to adoption.
And the first one
is really to full.
Right? It's what I'll call in
organizational inertia.
Because not only
do you have to
have this data centric
orientation of,
why we have incongruence and
the implications,
but you have to be able to,
manage the organizational
challenges of priorities and
politics and
processes and give
appropriate air cover and and
allow for
the infrastructure to
be created,
meaning coordination
across your processes and
facilitating collaboration.
It's a big ask. We know that.
But this is really the big
challenge is it's not really
the technology.
There is some
transformation costs.
Right? You do have to have,
triple store triple stores and
and the tool sets.
There is a skill
set requirements.
You must build
the ontologies correctly,
manage pipeline from
ingestion through,
application. So
this is the this
is the other side
of the coin,
and it's a real
side of the coin.
Mostly compounded
by what I call
the four horsemen of the data
management apocalypse.
Ignorance, arrogance,
obsolescence,
and power.
And we all know,
they run rampant through lots
of organizations,
and we have to kind of,
manage this organizational
challenge because
we're talking
about thinking about
data in a different
way. So we paint
you a composite
picture, and it starts with
let's call this
the infrastructure,
and the most important one is
this information
literacy concept
of understanding
the problem and
what it means, and why data
meaning is not
data processing,
and why this is
not a technology
problem, and the possibilities
of fixing this,
adopting standards,
doing appropriate
data hygiene.
You know, regardless
of how you do this,
whether you do a conventional
technology or semantic,
you have to manage the hygiene
of your data. If you're going
to do all that work,
do it strategically.
And that makes
sure that we have
to deal with, organizational,
dysfunction and
and, you know,
I've been tracking
data manager
for a while, and I call this
little g governance
in data management.
We're doing that pretty well.
We've learned
a lot about that.
But big g governance
of getting
the organization
to adopt a way
of thinking,
is the challenge that senior
execs are responsible
for implementing.
There are some requirements.
You know, as I said,
cognition and buy
in is critical.
Air cover is critical.
Understanding why
we have a problem
and the implications,
being able to to think of this
strategically, not
just tactically,
you know, fix the problem once
and get it off our plate.
Please, adopt this
idea of the semantic
trinity of identify,
describe,
and express. Right?
Identifiers, common meaning,
standards expression
with an accountability
and policy framework
around it that,
helps us with our
ecosystem management.
And then there are
three big areas.
Right? First one is
the architecture.
We talked a little
bit about this.
Right? Identity and
meaning resolution,
expressed in standards with
executable business rules,
and managing the pipeline,
which is itself
a challenge. Right?
You have to manage
it differently
in a semantic world,
to be able to,
you know, triple
ify it, you know,
turn it into triples and align
it with just the ontologies.
The business case must be made
over and over again to
all the appropriate
stakeholders. We have to think
about them from
the building blocks.
Right? You know,
that is identity
and meaning and
time and source
giving us context,
mathematical quality
value validation,
reusability of
our concepts and
how what does it
mean to manage
in a conceptual
data environment,
and traceability from,
through all
the transformations.
The audit is very
happy about that.
The business case of
the big three c's,
right, cost, capability,
and control,
plus the language of,
business in terms
of measurement
criteria. Right?
Efficiency of use and user
experience and
time to market,
and we can prove all this.
And we spend a lot of time
worrying about
the measurement criteria,
which I'm happy
to share against
the cost of
conversion. Right?
The inertia of our
organization.
This is all real
stuff. Right?
The physical
infrastructure and
transformation
we have to do to
map from conventional
to semantic.
And then there is an operating
model that, is required.
This is the data
hygiene operating
model, if you will.
But I've simplified
this. Right?
So the first part
of this is to
document what exists.
Build your inventory,
understand the data flow,
manage your lineage,
then you simplify all that,
authorize domains, names,
systems of records,
provisioning points,
classification of
what's important,
and data architecture,
capturing business
concepts and
translating them
into data concepts.
Let's not underestimate
the value
of this, the importance
of this.
Governance is required.
It's gonna be light touch,
but you're gonna
have roles and
skills and and policies
and, you know,
appropriate funding and
prioritization management and
escalation processes
and all that stuff.
And then how we
talk about it.
We talk about it
differently to
business, you know,
time to market,
use cases versus technology,
which is about integration and
scalability and
resiliency versus
control functions
about transparency
and traceability
and auditability.
So this is,
emphasizing
the importance of,
education and
messaging because
buy in is the fundamental task
if you're going to go
in this direction.
So here's some
concluding thoughts.
First, implementing a semantic
environment can be
done incrementally,
use case by use case. Right?
Which is that and that that
would be the way
you would do it,
and I would be
happy to talk to
you about what the appropriate
priorities are and how you
implement that.
There is a foundational
level level.
If the engineer
does correctly,
these are concepts,
and and we have to be able to
capture things like,
obligation and commitment and
control and party and role.
Then you and engineering that
is critical because this is
the scaffolding from which we
build the rest.
There is some investment.
It's not huge.
This is not a rip
and replace,
but there is some
investment in
technology. The
good news is it
plays nice with all of your
existing environments.
You do have to make
a transition,
and business value
is not always
immediately known
from the first
use case,
but all the rest of the use
cases become a lot easier.
So a little bit of
patience is required.
That's why leadership
is critical,
like finding
the right sponsor,
providing the appropriate
air cover,
you know,
organizational challenges
are necessary,
including the right
team leader for your
semantic journey.
And then process. Right?
This is a ability
to engineer,
test, add, test,
have policies test.
Those are all critical.
I will make these
slides available.
I did a good big
Ben Franklin,
cost benefit. They're both
legitimate size. Right?
I think the drivers
are overwhelming,
and this is a strategic value
that I would,
encourage everybody
to consider. But managing
organizational
cohesion is not,
an insignificant problem.
So this is me.
By all means, reach out.
I'm making this
course available
through my friends
at the Knowledge
Graph Conference.
Joaquin Melara is the CLL.
He's been terrific in helping
me get this organized.
So thank you for
your attention,
and, good luck to you.